Oh weird
[Music]
we've heard something I just don't
understand you
[Music]
hi everyone its charlie surprise
surprise there's a whole bunch of new
spider-man bar from home footers you're
dropping it all over the place this week
I think because it's the week after
Avengers end game so like they joke
about the Tom Hall and spoiler warning
that he gave before the last big trailer
that they dropped on Monday I think it's
mostly because of that and they've
started their official press tour
they're gonna be traveling all over the
world showing off clips so they'll be
way more footage posting in the next
month or so but obviously they confirm a
couple big details about the end of
Avengers and game the timeline and
what's going on during spider-man far
from home there's also another interview
clip from this where Tom Hong confirms
hydro-man during that big Venice canals
fight so I'll play that in a second but
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
will be do an Easter egg stuff all
summer long between spider-man far from
home more Avengers endgame and deleted
scenes and all that stuff there'll be a
whole bunch of that coming up plus we
have all the Marvel phase 4 stuff
through they're gonna drop at Comic Con
later this summer in July that'll be
after spider-man far from home though
we're also still doing that Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a spider-man comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this -
this is the clip of Tom Holland talking
about that hydro-man fight live up to
the expectations you had after shooting
that I mean it reminded me of the
hardest days of work I had it all was
that the hardest one yeah there's a
there's a shot in that trailer where I
get punched by hydro-man uh-huh and in
the day I'm sitting on the ground on
this thing called a ratchet so you
basically that you're attached to this
machine they press the button and you
zoom backwards smash into a wall and
there's a tip tank that's meant to soak
me in water and it's meant to look like
the waters smashing me into the wall
it's nine o'clock in the morning it's
October it's cold I know they haven't
heated the water in the tank I know this
is about to be a really tough morning
they got three two one action
they fired about my whiz back I hit the
wall completely dry and then you hear
the SFX guy go Cherie and then
so even though they're calling that
character hydro-man and you see the
easter-egg on the boat for hydro man's
first appearance in the comics behind
ned leads when they're in the canals
like i explained in my last big
spider-man trailer video that i posted
yesterday with a whole different clip
talking about the multiverse the
director said that they're using a lot
of these b-list spider-man villains but
they're taking a very different spin on
them so instead of making them look like
humans like they did in the original
comics when they appeared or during the
90s spider-man animated series if you
ever watch that they're making them seem
more like elementals and it's all part
of Mysterio's plan here so obviously
there's a big twist but they haven't
revealed that in any of the interviews
yet so it's still a little bit of
speculation about how Mysterio in these
elementals are connected but if you've
read a lot of Mysterio storylines during
the spider-man comics you probably have
a pretty good idea for where they're
headed with this when they're talking
about the timeline at the beginning of
spider-man far from home like yeah it
picks up in the moments after avengers
endgame just confirming that it does
sound like Tom Holland is genuinely
confused why they're still in high
school like they joke about it being a
big plot hole but the Russos and Kevin
Feige separately sort of explained
what's going on with that the reason why
they're still in school is because the
moment they come back after Hulk snaps
everyone back is because they come back
at the exact moment that they left so
they haven't changed they haven't aged a
day
so essentially there's still a bunch of
16 17 year old kids your follow up
question is then what happened to the
other people that they went to school
with are they in college now how is that
going to be explained are there any
people that we'll see who they used to
go to high school with who are now way
older that will show up during the movie
based on some of the jokes that the
Russos made about that I don't think
that we're gonna see a whole lot of that
but they will reference some of it at
the beginning of the film like during
the spider-man far from home trailer you
see Iron Man drawings all over the place
when you see them in school here in MJ
walks in and they start talking to each
other in the background you can see all
the Iron Man drawings behind them on the
school wall so clearly they're going to
be addressing some of that at the
beginning of the film but for the most
part a lot of the core kid characters
all got snapped so that's why they're
all the same age like Flash Thompson
douchebag as he is also got snaps so
that's why he's still the same age they
also confirmed who this character is -
people are like is he gonna be playing
Amadeus Cho like everyone was thinking
of every Asian character they could
think of from the spider-man or
Marvel Comics but the director explained
that he's actually playing an original
character he's not someone big from the
comics and he's actually more of a
romantic rival for MJ for Peter Parker
he's a bit of a poser in the way that
Mysterio is a superhero poser so you can
see what they're doing spider-man has
villains quote unquote so to speak in
his everyday life as a high school kid
for the things that he wants in his
normal life but he also has villains to
defeat in his superhero life as a
spider-man persona I also loved when Tom
Holland is talking about filming that
funeral scene at the end of Avengers
endgame I was told that it was a wedding
the same thing actually happened for
pretty much all those other actors there
was an interview clip where Kevin Feige
was actually joking about that he said
for the longest time we called it the
wedding scene but you know that the
amazing shot that Joe Neff did at the
end at tony's funeral that pushes past
more cast members than you might have
ever seen in one shot before by the way
that's the first time publicly or
privately I've ever called it the
funeral on the call sheets in the script
it was called the wedding it was called
the wedding scene and and we still refer
to it we shot it almost two years ago we
refer to as though with that amazing day
we shot the wedding shot and it's not
stitched together it's it they were all
there you had things like Tom Holland
who played spider-man coming up to me
and going is that Michelle Pfeiffer over
there she she and this cuz cuz we hadn't
released that man the wasp yet that was
an amazing that was an amazing day
before we saw the actual ending an Iron
Man was the one to die that was my big
theories that they were gonna end with
the wedding of Pepper Potts and Tony
Stark there's a lot of hearsay in
conjecture and speculation about why
Robert Downey jr. wanted to leave the
Marvel Cinematic Universe would they
have changed the ending if he wanted to
stay on and continue playing Iron Man
but the Russos actually did say that his
very famous I am Iron Man
snap moment that he went out on they
actually had to talk Robert Downey jr.
and he didn't want to say that line
originally but they had a very special
dinner while they were shooting the
other scenes in the film and they just
happened to have a really powerful
producer that Robert Downey jr. was
friends with at dinner with them in the
other producer Joel silver who's
actually a really big power player in
Hollywood said Robert you absolutely
have to say that line
I am iron
so after that he agreed to it the
roosters are like okay we have to go
shoot this scene and that's when they
shot the I am Iron Man
snap scene so that actually happened
pretty late in the game while they were
still editing the film they'll be all
kinds of stories like this when the DVD
comes out later this summer - there's
still probably like one or two people in
the world that haven't seen the film
like they found a person in Jimmy Kimmel
studio the one man in the world that has
not seen endgame so once we get ready
for the big blu-ray DVD release I will
do some giveaway stuff for that - the
other big thing that they talked about
during this interview - is Maria Hill
talking about how she only really had
scenes in London but I think they also
filmed a lot of this Venice stuff in the
base people are like is Maria Hill going
to wind up being the chameleon is the
chameleon gonna be acting as Nick Fury
during the film they're just a couple
scenes during the film where they're
playing it very James Bond II Face Swap
style so people are like is the
chameleon gonna be pretending to be any
of the other characters during this they
haven't completely confirmed that the
chameleon is in the film yet but the
actor that everyone thinks is the
chameleon is actually in the background
of these cave shots when they're in
their secret base talking to Mysterio
Maria hill and Nick Fury
this is the actor you can see him in the
background of this shot so obviously in
this moment Nick Fury really is Nick
Fury talking to spider-man and Maria
hill really is Maria hill reacting to
all this stuff but it is totally
possible that they have the chameleon
doing something like that during the
film I explained a little bit about what
the director has said about the overall
plot of the film in my last big trailer
video so I'll post that spider-man link
at the end of this there's another big
Avengers endgame video that I'm working
on I'll try to post that tomorrow
obviously more Game of Thrones coming up
this weekend so leave all your video
requests in the comments below
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big spider-man video Rachel
autumn ready please email me on the
about page my channel so I can get your
details while you wait for everything
click here for that last big spider-man
far from home scene where Mysterio
explains the multiverse and click here
to rewatch the full spider-man far from
home trailer a billion more times thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you